[Music]
say you've been caring for an animal and
you actually do have to do that little
bit of syringe feeding and then the next
day you go in there to shrimps feed it
and it wants to eat you you know you've
done a good
[Music]
job good afternoon tiki winklers alyssa
speaking how can i help
[Music]
welcome to tiggy winkles the world's
busiest wildlife hospital meet sharon
jacobs she's a senior nurse here at
tiggy winkles
this adorable wildlife hospital is named
after a character from a beatrix potter
children's book mrs tiggy winkle
but this isn't the place you take your
sick dog like florence the british
bulldog right
flow
this is for all wild animals found
injured x-rays
taken we deal with all british wildlife
as in foxes badgers deer with mice they
treat rabbits bats big birds small birds
and very very cute hedgehogs oh just
look at him swimming
they get around 10 000 animals through
the door each year with a wide range of
sicknesses and injuries okay this guy
come into us about two weeks ago and
she fractured her tibia so we've
actually put a plaster of paris on which
is a cast
the wildlife hospital is just like a
human one luckily for the animals there
isn't a waiting room any animal that
comes through the door the first thing
is they do they go through triage so and
literally they are medically assessed
there see if there's any injuries see if
they need a drip see if they need any
antibiotics painkillers and stuff like
that within 24 hours they normally get
reassessed by the vet and any sort of
like medical treatment or wounds or
injuries or x-rays or anything is
normally done then once the animal is
fully fit as in medically in sight and
we want it to go outside so if it was a
bird for argument's sake it would go
into an avery if it was a deer will go
down our paddocks and again once we're
happy with them then the aim is to get
everything back to the world we don't
keep anything because it looks cute and
fluffy
it's quite nice when it comes to
actually releasing the animal and now
and again some of the deer will actually
bolt off and then turn around and stare
at you're going what's going on here so
it's quite nice
i think the aim of tigger winkles is
obviously to save the animal's life but
also to educate people about how to
treat them how to get the animal back to
the wild if you do see an animal that's
injured to take it to a wildlife
hospital so it can get better and then
that way this little fella can rest up
with his cast
you